joining me now with reaction is House
Majority Whip Steve Scalise author of
the great new book back in the game
along with Tom Holman former acting
director of ice and a fox news
contributor congressman let's start with
you the House GOP only has 12 days left
was I too harsh in my angle there on
where I'm land Laura I think you laid
out the landscape really well and
clearly this goes back to Barack Obama's
presidency when he created the daca
problem without ever trying to solve it
he said literally come to America
illegally bring your kids here illegally
he never tried to fix it they never in
fact when Pelosi had the house they had
a supermajority in the Senate they never
tried to bring a bill to fix the problem
they wanted a political issue and so
they never tried to fix it as you
pointed out again President Trump comes
into office Chuck Schumer initially was
willing to work with him on a solution
to daca that included funding for the
wall then the radical left went nuts in
Schumer pulled that deal off the table
we've tried to pass bills through the
house to solve the interior loophole
problems that you've cited so many times
as well as funding the wall not one
Democrat we've had two different
approaches on this so no matter where
you are on this there was a chance for
you to vote to solve the problem not one
Democrat voted for any of those shut
down the government right well we still
have by the way in the next two weeks
the Department of Homeland Security's
budget expires at the end of November
and this is gonna be one more battle
that we're gonna have and it's gonna
happen in the next few weeks right here
here hearing a Tom Joni Ernst was on one
of the other shows last night or
yesterday I watched it last night
Republican senator from Iowa was
basically saying we can't shut down this
government for the wall we can't do
these are the Republicans that we're
dealing with here
I mean Steve Scalise has done a yeoman's
work with everything he's been through
try to stand for the American people
they're not many who will you've seen
this you and I sat here at this table
Tom and you said to me watch what
happens it's gonna get worse and worse
and worse and right now we have 5,000
people a week crossing our border
illegally
separate from the caravan look I've been
at this game for 34 years and and
unfortunately everything I said is
coming true and I tell you we had some
great Republican congressman take the
by the horn head McConville that bill
was a great bill and other Republicans
and some of the Republicans didn't
support of course no Democrats did but
that fixed the problem it fixed to the
loopholes it fixed all of the polls and
gave some relief perfect bill and I said
it many times you shoul or I don't care
for your public and Democrat there's no
downside and securing the border none
but Paul Ryan is on his way out I like
him personally but he has never wanted
to fund this wall I'm gonna say it
everyone Paul Ryan has never wanted to
fund this wall he didn't want to deal
with this problem for a whole bunch of
reasons he was never comfortable with
the president's immigration agenda I
think that looking back that ended up
really hurting the Republicans if you
don't have someone at the helm
who's championing what the president is
doing and I don't think McConnell really
want to do it either I mean he talks a
good game but I don't think either of
them really wanted to do it we were able
to get a billion and a half dollars of
new funding for border wall in this
year's budget obviously we want more the
president's asked for five billion
dollars I'd like to see us get there
we've had a number of bills to try to
solve that problem let me make this
point about the end-of-the-year funding
for the Department of Homeland Security
when people talk about a government
shutdown they try to use it in a
pejorative term to try to scare people
over 70% of the United States government
is fully funded until the end of next
year's fiscal year including the
Department of Defense which is
critically important in the past you saw
Obama use our troops as hostages to try
to say hey the troops won't get paid
unless you give me X Y or Z we have now
fully funded the entire department
defense including given a pay raise to
our troops that goes through September
30th of next year so now all we're
talking about is an important part of
government but it's less than 30 percent
including the Department of Homeland
Security that's where the wall funding
comes in so there will no being a
widespread government shutdown it's all
about funding Department Homeland
Security in building the wall I have to
I have to have this in addition to the
wall funding ice needs funding for beds
because if I just can't detain people
arrested at the border and this cuts
release again more for caravans won't
come there's no consequence to
deterrence why would they stop detainees
Rodney Scott I know you know him I've
interviewed him so many times including
down at the border in San Diego he said
what we're seeing contrary to what all
of these bleeding-heart
Media types most of whom would not
sponsor illegal immigrants if they had
to personally guarantee their economic
independence they would never do it but
they talk a good emotional game when you
see the pictures the sad pictures of the
people fleeing that but Rodney Scott
knows this sector better than anyone
said this let's watch what I saw on the
border yesterday was not people walking
up to Border Patrol agents and asking to
claim asylum they were chanting waving
the honduran flag and throwing rocks at
the agents if they were truly asylum
seekers they would have just walked up
with her hands up and surrendered and
that did not take place and I know
Rodney sky is a great American patriot
I'll add this look the board changes
that sent the tear gas out set it on
rock throwers they just send that women
and children of course you know the wind
drifts and that happens however you know
I wanted to throw a shout out to NBC
they did a great story tonight know what
they did they interviewed that woman
with a to chill net pitcher and she come
on said that she was coming to country
language to join her husband was illegal
in the country Louisiana nothing about
fear and persecution so I hope that's
Exhibit A and her future political
asylum cases exactly what I've said
people are coming to get a job or people
come here to rejoin so it's a big lie
what I'm trying what we're trying to
illustrate for people is that we
actually need real reporters who put
aside whether they don't like Trump like
Trump and they say this is how we got
here this real persecutions happening
all over the world congressman you know
what's happening to people like hacia BB
is woman in Pakistan at this point to
Laura president Trump was very clear and
saying there is a legal way to come to
America to seek asylum and there's an
illegal way we're not going to let you
just storm a border and climb a fence go
to a port of entry and state your case
make your claim that's the way it's
going to help us I think that's where
the even the tijuana mayor said they're
getting overridden with some of these
people that are coming to attack law
enforcement officers not to seek asylum
and by the way most of them passed
through at least one other country
already how many laws they violate Tom
how many laws they vie like before they
get to San Ysidro on average level so
the the with anther country the enter
country legally first first first crimes
of misdemeanor however allow these
people based on our intelligence have
been deported before so when they enter
the country let's a felon
but one thing I want to say they'll put
the Nasser's and tear guys need to get
this out for those days tears put on a
uniform strap back on your hip get rocks
thrown at you and tell me there wasn't a
better responses non-lethal law
enforcement I was proper concerned
they're being assaulted and where were
they when the Obama administration was
using - your gas oh yeah back in 2013
you have to disperse the crowd how do
you disperse the crowd but Rihanna calls
it terrorism guys Rihanna's upset she
doesn't have security at her concerts
all right let's look let everybody
through her concerts anyone wants to go
on stage with Rihanna not only can they
go on stage but they can get a hot meal
at our house afterward I don't think so
guys thanks so much